hey yo I got my competition trembling
they wanna know if Harry Mack is friends
with Eminem does Eminem know me I can't
be certain but I can tell you this much
yo I didn't hurt him so many times
playing the CDs on repeat and studying
the way this dude is such a beast on the
beat yeah but he ain't never
acknowledged me thus far it makes me
nervous thinking about him here in my
bars I mean I'm in my own shuttle and
I'm trying to blast off but I can't
imagine being peep by the Rap God I'm
about to break it down y'all know that
my freestyle's crazy uh throwing shaded
rappers so I leave em Shady yeah can't
nobody Rock This Way Matt connector
beats like M to Dr Dre okay breaking it
down off the tip of the Dome every time
that a rhyme and I get in the zone down
on crazy whenever I'm rapping hopefully
yo we can make this happen maybe Eminem
watch is wired maybe he can hear this
fire maybe he gonna hear what I'm doing
right now and feel just a little
inspired